Speaker 1: I want to talk next about one of
the the real implications of this bogus Arizona
audit that's taking place of absentee ballots,
looking for bamboo fibers and all sorts of
other stuff.
The the impact of the Arizona audit is not
going to be Joe Biden retroactively loses
Arizona.
The impact of the Arizona audit is not going
to be.
Joe Biden is removed from the White House
and Trump is reinstated, to use the word that
they've been throwing around for the last
week or so.
But there is going to be an impact from this
audit.
And there's a really good article in NPR about
this by Miles Parks called Experts Call It
a clown show.
But Arizona audit is a disinformation blueprint,
explaining it's not an audit.
It's an audit in name only, according to Matt
Masterson, a former Department of Homeland
Security official who helped lead the election
security prep for the last election.
He says it's a threat to the overall confidence
of democracy, all in pursuit of continuing
a narrative that we know to be a lie.
This is a really important thing to understand.
Maybe there are people who think the Arizona
audit and the search for bamboo fibers and
all of this stuff could lead to a change in
the Arizona results or a change in the 2020
results.
Overall, it's not going to.
But even without achieving that, it still
is achieving something that should be very
scary to all of us, which is it continues
to put in people's minds the idea that our
elections are just a free for all.
They don't work when a candidate wins by millions
and millions of votes, maybe they actually
lost by millions and millions of votes.
And it just further reinforces the idea that,
hey, the election results are sort of like
opinion, much the same way where you might
like one flavor bubble tea.
And I like a different flavor.
Or I might think that one type of cherry ice
cream is good.
And you might say, no, Cherry Garcia is the
best one.
Right.
It equates a position on abortion.
Like what's my opinion about whether abortion
should or shouldn't be legal to who one is
just an opinion and we can challenge it and
we can use any mechanism that we can think
of to try to challenge that.
That's the crisis that Matt Masterson is pointing
out here.
Masterson says the strategy chosen by the
Arizona Republican state Senate leaders is
working as intended to undermine confidence
in the outcome of last year's vote.
And this is the point.
Even if it doesn't overturn it, it undermines
confidence in elections in general.
The process is a simple exercise in how disinformation
spreads and takes hold.
In twenty twenty one, and experts fear it
presents a blueprint for other states and
lawmakers to follow one that's already showing
signs of being emulated across the country.
And this is the key line right here.
Masterson says now we have a playbook out
there where if you don't like the results,
by the way, in an election that wasn't particularly
close, you claim you didn't lose.
And in fact, the process itself was rigged
against you.
And the steps are first create a false reality.
That's the first step.
The second step is hit the airwaves, which
they did very early and continue to do.
The third step is used doubt to sow more doubt,
and then you go into next election with people
already primed to doubt whatever it is that
they hear from you, that is the three step
process.
And unfortunately, I don't know if these people
are evil geniuses who are thinking, hey, you
know what?
This Arizona thing is not going to accomplish
anything in terms of Arizona 2020, but this
is going to seed doubt and it'll create a
pretext for people to claim any election we
lose was fraudulent.
I don't know that they're really evil geniuses
and they're thinking in those terms, but it
doesn't matter because that's the effect that
it has.
And so much like I said in the last segment,
when we start seeing these new Trump rallies,
supposedly later this month, maybe not until
July, when we start seeing them, what is going
to be the mood of the people in the crowd
about the legitimacy, the legitimacy of any
election?
Because I believe that what we're going to
see here very clearly is, you know, Trump's
going to pick his favorites for 20, 22, and
maybe a whole bunch of them are going to lose.
Maybe some will win.
We don't yet know.
But if they lose, yes, it hurts.
Trump's shot at twenty twenty four if he can't
successfully be the kingmaker in twenty twenty
two.
But does anybody have any doubt that they're
going to say, guys, listen, Democrats control
the House now.
Democrats control the Senate.
Joe Biden controls the White House.
Of course they rigged it.
So it seems to me a foregone conclusion if
they don't get what they want in twenty, twenty
two, they're going to say it was all fraudulent.
And the stuff they're doing now, including
in Arizona, is going to be used as a pretext
to gin up the idea that if you don't like
the results, it's totally legit now in American
politics to say the results were rigged.
Very scary stuff.
Let me know what you think.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
All right, welcome back to the program.
It is a it's a great day, it's a great show
today.
We may even keep this one.
Remember that we are mostly dependent on people
who grab memberships at Join Pakman Dotcom.
Today's the last day where you can take advantage
of that wild Memorial Day discount.
The coupon code is Memorial twenty one, and
you can use it on any membership, quite literally,
any membership you like at.
Join Pakman Dotcom.